vielen dank dass sie wieder zu uns
gekommen sind um uns zu informieren über
die
wohnanlage und die neuesten
informationen die sie haben der
bundesgesundheitsminister beginnt dann
hätte er lieber herr dp meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren die traurige
zahl von über 100.000 corona toten in
deutschland ist zu beklagen wir haben
rekord infektionszahlen von über 75.000
infektionen an einem tag eine inzidenz
von fast 440 wir werden erstmals in
dieser pandemie in größerem umfang
nämlich bis zu 100 intensivpatienten
innerhalb deutschlands mit großem
aufwand verlegen müssen unter
beteiligung ja auch der luftwaffe die
lage ist dramatisch ernst zu ernst wie
noch zu keinem zeitpunkt in dieser
pandemie und wir sitzen hier jede woche
und weisen auf den ernst der lage hin
aber zu wenig passiert zu oft zu spät
vorletzte woche haben wir gesagt es ist
fünf nach zwölf
letzte woche haben wir gesagt es ist
zehn nach zwölf es ist mittlerweile halb
eins aber der weckruf ist noch immer
nicht überall angekommen
einige sagen man wolle jetzt erst mal
zehn tage schauen
sich zeit geben aber die pflegekräfte
auf den intensivstationen die haben
keine zehn tage zum schauen
zu viele auch in politischer
verantwortung oder ein künftiger
verantwortung scheinen zu denken wird
schon irgendwie gut gehen
wird es aber nicht jedenfalls nicht von
alleine
denn es fängt ja erst an
wer glaubt dass diese welle nur durch
baden württemberg bayern thüringen und
sachsen geht und den rest deutschlands
verschont
diese welle wird auch in deutschland
weiter gen westen und norden ziehen das
ist ziemlich sicher
was noch offen ist ist die frage wie
hoch ihr regionaler scheitelpunkt sein
wird wie stark die belastung jeweils
regional des gesundheitswesens werden
wird wie viele tote und
intensivpatienten es gibt
das haben wir in der hand da kann man
einen unterschied machen einen
entscheidenden unterschied wird die
jeweilige impfquote auch machen das
testen macht einen unterschied aber für
unsere momentane
schwierige ernste lage macht ganz
kurzfristig nur eines den entscheidenden
unterschied die zahl der kontakte muss
runter deutlich runter es nützt alles
nichts
das heißt es braucht deutlich mehr
kontakt beschränkung das heißt
konsequentes zweig plus wie wir es
übrigens seit über drei wochen fordern
das heißt mindestens das absagen von
großveranstaltungen und feiern es
braucht bundesweit mehr kontakt
beschränkung das beste wäre die mpk die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz tag schon
in den nächsten tagen und entscheidet
was zu entscheiden ist die letzte bei
drei wochen zu spät das sollte nicht
wieder passiert
gleichzeitig verkämpfen wir uns aktuell
auf zuviel nebenschauplätzen wir
diskutieren mit viel politischer kraft
über im pflichten die aber gut nichts
helfen es werden neue krone räte
gefordert und gebildet obwohl es
natürlich seit 18 monaten krisenstäbe
und wissenschaftlichen rat gibt und mehr
schadet sicher nicht aber es hilft eben
auch kurzfristig nicht
und leider ist auch das verlegen von
patienten oder das notwendige
verschieben von operationen von
planbaren operationen nur
symptombekämpfung
denn 80 oder 100 patienten innerhalb
deutschlands zu verlegen das geht
vielleicht zwei mal vielleicht dreimal
aber das geht nicht unbegrenzt oft die
betten werden ja auch im rest
deutschlands knapper werden
das war übrigens auf konsens gestern bei
der konferenz mit meinen kolleginnen und
kollegen aus den ländern
wir müssen jetzt diese welle stoppen
sonst erleben wir genau das
was wir immer vermeiden wollten eine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems
der tanker der auf die kaimauer zufährt
den professor wieder vergangene woche
geschrieben hat er wurde bisher nicht
gebremst im gegenteil er wird immer
schneller er fährt mit voller fahrt und
je länger wir das jetzt laufen lassen
desto drastischer werden am ende die
notwendigen maßnahmen sein müssen
dieser übergang zwischen einer
bisherigen regierung und einer neuen das
nicht zu verzögerungen führen
es braucht in dieser nationalen notlage
das zusammenstehen aller
verantwortlichen jetzt
zum abschluss meine damen und herren
wenigstens eine gute nachricht
die impfkampagne zieht wieder an
erstmals haben wir wieder über 100.000
erstimpfungen sogar in den letzten zwei
tagen in den letzten drei tagen zusammen
über 300.000 impfungen sind immerhin
fast 0,4 prozent der bevölkerung
in dieser woche gab es auch bereits
schon zwei millionen auffrischimpfung
alleine gestern wieder über 600.000
damit es jeder fünfte über 60 jährige
zusätzlich geschützt durch eine dritte
impfung und fast schon zehn prozent der
gesamtbevölkerung und anhand der
bestellung sehen wir dieser trend hält
an wir verzeichnen hier inzwischen
rekorde
allein in dieser und den nächster in der
nächsten woche gehen zusammen insgesamt
18 millionen booster impfdosen in die
versorgung an die länder arztpraxen und
großhändler wenn ich also die dosen die
wir diese woche ausgeliefert haben und
die die wir montag dienstag ausliefern
zusammennehmen sind das 18 millionen
booster impfdosen
aber einen impfzahlen sehen wir auch das
aktuell dass noch nicht alles verändert
werden kann wir haben jetzt dreieinhalb
millionen impfungen in den letzten
sieben tagen im verhältnis zu 18
millionen ausgelieferten
impfdosen zeigt dass ist eben auch noch
was in den kühlschränken und
dass sie müssen wir jetzt miteinander
und das werde ich mit den
verantwortlichen besprechen ein bisschen
aufpassen dass das verhältnis von
verengungen und ausgelieferten dosen
stimmt denn bei uns in den zentralen
lagern ist der impfstoff sechs monate
haltbar vor ort in den kühlschränken nur
drei bis vier wochen deswegen jahr
wollen und werden wir natürlich
beliefert bestellung
bestmöglich bedienen insbesondere auch
bei moderner bei beyond es kennen sie
die bekannten
beschränkungen aber wir müssen das eben
so machen dass das in einem verhältnis
steht dass jede woche verändert und das
was ausgeliefert wird weil ansonsten das
möchte ich jedenfalls vermeiden zu viel
möglicherweise in zu kurzer zeit von
verfall betroffen sein könnte und das
werden wir eben mit allen
verantwortlichen besprechen wie wir das
gut aus steuern das am ende bestellung
und impfungen richtigen verhältnis sind
vor allem aber möchte ich abschließend
allen ärztinnen und ärzten einen
helferinnen und helfern allen
verantwortlichen in den ländern in den
impfzentren und vor ort dafür danken
dass sie wieder schwung in die
impfkampagne gebracht haben jede impfung
gibt hoffnung dass dieser winter doch
nicht so dunkel wird wie es aktuell
aussieht
wenn es vielen dank und herr professor
100.000
476 menschen leben meine damen und
herren mehr als 100.000 menschen haben
seit beginn der pandemie durch ko mit 19
in unserem land ihr leben verloren und
lasse nämlich bevor ich mich meiner
heutigen aufgabe wieder mit mir ihnen
die einschätzung zu geben uns alle kurz
bitten einige sekunden inne zu halten
und dieser verstorbenen und ihrer
hinterbliebenen gedenken
meine damen und herren welche todeszahl
wurde uns denn überzeugen dass coop 19
keine leichte erkrankung ist uns und zum
impfen motivieren
wie viele menschen müssen dennoch
sterben damit wir unser verhalten
anpassen und die krankenhäuser und das
pflegepersonal entlasten was muss denn
noch geschehen damit wir davon überzeugt
sind dass wir alle verfügbaren maßnahmen
einleiten müssen um diese vierte welle
zu brechen
ich möchte alle auffordern helfen sie
alle diese vierte welle zu brechen wie
können schwere verläufe überlastung der
kliniken todesfälle nur dann verhindern
wenn wir verhindern dass sich menschen
anstecken ich erwarte jetzt von den
entscheidern dass sie alle maßnahmen
einleiten um gemeinsam die fallzahlen
herunterzuholen
wir müssen jetzt unsere kontakte so weit
es geht reduzieren mit jedem kontakt den
wir nicht haben
mit jedem treffen auf das wir verzichten
mit jeder menschenmenge die wir meiden
helfen wir dabei die ausbreitung des
virus zu verlangsamen und
bitte lassen sich impfen bzw auffrischen
bitte halten sie alle in den
bundesländern beschlossenen maßnahmen
auch ein
und halten sie über all die a und l
regeln und auch wenn sie geimpft sind
oder genießen die maske gehört auch bei
2g und 3g immer dazu unsere auf mund und
nase
ich gehe heute etwas detailliert auf die
lage intensivstation ein so wie sich die
zahlen an anthes intensiv registers
darstellen aktuell werden mehr als 4000
patienten und patientinnen
intensivmedizinisch behandelt die zahlen
gehen aber steil nach oben und zwar in
allen bundesländern innerhalb von nur
sieben tagen wurden ca 2000 patientinnen
erstmalig auf eine igs aufgenommen der
großteil ist zwischen 50 und 79 jahre
alt aber auch die anderen altersgruppen
sind immer häufiger betroffen
85 prozent
der aktuell behandelten co mit 90
patienten bemüht eine form der beatmung
zurzeit werden mehr als 2000 sogar
invasiv beatmet ein teil von ihnen
benötigt zusätzlich eine eco behandlung
also die künstliche lunge das ist sehr
belastend für patienten aber auch für
die pflegekräfte
aktuell liegt der anteil der kugel 19
patienten bei den betreibern
intensivbetten bundesweit bei 18,9
prozent das mag vielleicht für den einen
oder anderen wenig klingen aber es
entspricht ja quasi jedem fünften
überhaupt verfügbaren bett und ich
möchte es noch mal klar machen diese
betten werden ja für alle
intensivmedizinisch und patienten
benötigt nicht nur für tobit 19
patienten 70 prozent aller
intensivbereich in deutschland meldet
eine vollständige oder teilweise
eingeschränkte betriebssituation das ist
ein höchststand in der pandemie ja es
gibt noch freie intensivbetten aber
diese freien betten werden dadurch
erkauft dass in den belasteten regionen
zb geplante operationen verschoben
werden oder ausgesetzt werden zb
tumor-operation
oder transplantationen das heißt andere
patienten bekommen ihre behandlung nicht
mehr
diese situation geht zu lasten aller
dort ist jetzt die versorgung
eingeschränkt und wenn die infektion
nicht weiter gebremst werden oder sagen
über wenn sie nicht endlich massiv
gebremst werden dann wird natürlich die
versorgung in ganz deutschland
eingeschränkt sein und eines muss uns
auch allen bewusst sein und das will ich
noch mal ganz klar sagen ohne die
massnahmen und ohne die impfungen wäre
die situation airfield schlimmer noch
die zahl der schwerstkranken todesfälle
wurde ja um ein vielfaches höher liegen
das wären viele
100.000 menschen
impfungen schützen sehr gut vor einem
schweren verlauf wer vollständig geimpft
ist erkrankt deutlich seltener an kuwait
19 auch wenn der eben schutz im laufe
der zeit nachlässt wer vollständig
geimpft ist muss auch deutlich seltener
ins krankenhaus auf die intensivstation
und er hat und sie hat ein deutlich
geringeres risiko an komik 19 zu
verstärken wir brauchen in der
derzeitigen lage
aber zusätzlich kontakt reduktion
maßnahmen und die verbreitung des virus
zu verlangsamen wir brauchen eine
massive reduktion der kontakte jetzt
sofort eine hohe impfquoten und eine
niedrige incident das ist der beste
schutz vor kurve 19 das ist der beste
schutz für risikogruppen aber es ist
noch der beste schutz für alle die sich
im moment noch gar nicht impfen lassen
können also alle kinder unter 12
es ist der beste schutz für uns alle
lassen sie mich auch nochmal kurz auf
die korona wahrnimmt eingehen die etwa
eigentlich noch nie so wichtig wie sie
jetzt ist erstens jeder der ticona wand
installiert und nutzt der kann andere
nutzerin nutzer nach einer bestätigten
infektionen warnen oder auch selbst
gewarnt werden und zwar schnell und
direkt indem er das positive ergebnis
eines tests mitteilt zweitens treffen in
innenräumen sollten ja prinzipiell
gemieden werden aber falls sie trotzdem
nötig sind können sie die check in
funktion der app nutzen im falle einer
bestätigen infektion werden dann alle
personen die sich in diesem raum
aufgehalten haben cluster genau gewarnt
drittens sie können in der korona vanek
ihre impf genesen und ihre tests
zertifikate sicher ablegen und bei
bedarf vorzeigen und wenn sie umgekehrt
die echtheit der zertifikate überprüfen
möchten nutzen sie bitte ebenfalls die
kostenlose kopf passt check-up
schrecklicher name aber sie funktioniert
und lassen sie sich bitte auch den
personalausweis zeigen
nur dann können wir sicher sein dass die
zertifikat auch echt sind und zu den
personen gehören es ist auch bei 2g und
3g absolut essentiell dass sie
kontrolliert werden also nutzen sie
unsere apps sie sind sicher und
entsprechen den höchsten
datenschutzbestimmungen
bislang wurde die korona waren es schon
knapp 37 millionen mal runtergeladen und
je mehr menschen sie nutzen desto besser
ist das für uns alle ich fasse noch
einmal zusammen wir haben bereits drei
kurven 19 wählen und einen harten winter
hin der kommende winter hängt von
unserem verhalten
und von der entscheidung der
verantwortungsträger kontakt
reduzierende maßnahmen zu erlassen
wir stehen an einer kreuzung wir haben
eine wahl wir können den weg wählen der
ins chaos führt und zu einem schlechten
ende er kündigt tanker vor die kaimauer
fahren oder den der das
gesundheitssystem entlastet und
vielleicht ein friedliches
weihnachtsfest ermöglicht und auch noch
viel mehr menschen am weihnachtstisch
sitzen lässt lassen sie uns unserer
verantwortung für das allgemeinwohl
nachkommt gemeinsam mit allen kräften
daran arbeiten dass wir diese pandemie
beenden als ob unser leben davon abhänge
vielen dank es gibt viele fragen
linke beginnt und dann
rechts hatten
machten sich alle und gesichter erkennen
ich habe eine frage sowohl an den
spanier als sehr gern wieder und zwar zu
der neuen variante die in südafrika
aufgetaucht ist können sie uns bitte was
dazu sagen wie gefährlich diese variante
ist gibt es schon hinweise dass
bisherige immunisierung
nicht helfen konnten und wie kann man
sich dagegen schützen
zuerst einmal das zeigt übrigens wie
wichtig genomsequenzierung ist das haben
wir übrigens bis heute durchgängig auf
hohem niveau auch in deutschland seitdem
wir angefangen haben vor über einem jahr
das zu verstärken ist durch ebendiese
genomsequenzierung in südafrika die auch
dort vergleichsweise gute kapazitäten
haben diese variante bekannt geworden
und aufgefallen sie hat eine hohe zahl
von mutationen die zumindest erstmal
auch anlass zu sorge sind ob sie
sozusagen die frage welche
krankheitsverläufe welche infektiosität
es gibt verändert oder nicht das kann
noch nicht abschließend gesagt werden
die frage ob die impfstoffe genau so gut
wirken oder nicht auch nicht die
entsprechenden tests finden statt die
sowohl die institute sind im kontakt
miteinander dazu die vero die
weltgesundheitsorganisation und
natürlich auch die regierung wir haben
heute morgen entschieden dass südafrika
und welche nachbarländer genau da möchte
ich jetzt einfach abwarten die
beratungen laufe des vormittags weitere
länder in der region zur
virusvarianten gebieten erklärt werden
werden
kurzfristig das bedeutet dass eine
einreise oder eine beförderung durch
fluggesellschaft nach deutschland nun
auch für deutsche möglich ist und diese
müssen ob geimpft gewesen oder nicht für
14 tage in quarantäne
das ist eine erforderliche proaktive
präventive schutzmaßnahmen um einen
eintrag nach deutschland hinein zu
vermeiden wir sind auch in kontakt mit
der eu-kommission sie haben gesehen frau
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen hat
angekündigt dass auch die eu
entsprechende maßnahmen ergreifen will
das vereinigte königreich und israel
haben das auch getan unser ziel muss
sein den eintrag dieser variante so weit
es geht zu vermeiden
das ist das letzte was wir jetzt in
unserer momentanen lage noch brauchen
können das in die welle hinein noch eine
zusätzliche variante kommt möchte
abschließend sagen dass ich den
südafrikanischen behörden einfach auch
für transparenz in dieser frage das ist
ja für südafrika keine leichte situation
wenn jetzt alle länder wieder
reisebeschränkungen
machen das ist für das land schwierig
und umso anerkennenswerter
finde ich es dass sie eben sehr schnell
diese transparenz hergestellt haben und
das ist da eine gute kooperation gibt
und wo wir können werden wir auch wie
bisher südafrika unterstützen
alles was minister sparen gesagt hat ist
genau zu treffen ich ergänze es noch mal
für einige details das ist eine variante
die sehr viele mutationen trägt und zwar
insbesondere diesem spike protein einige
der mutationen sind schon vorhergesehen
worden das sind dann so genannte
konvergente mutationen da sind einige in
den ställen die
dort geschehen sind wo die antikörper
bin wo neutralisierende antikörper oder
auch therapeutische antikörper verbinden
es sind auch einige stellen dort in der
nähe dieses vorgehen kleve zeit diese
diese stelle wo das wo die aufnahme des
virus in zellen erhöht wird das spricht
dafür dass es eine erhöhte transmission
sein könnte
und es gibt noch weitere mutationen die
bislang von denen bislang nicht ganz
klar ist was sie biologisch bedeuten das
heißt also wir sind tatsächlich in sehr
großer sorge
wir sind jetzt wenn wir sprechen ist
gerade eine video-konferenz die mit den
kollegen in südafrika vor ort
stattfindet wir sind sehr froh dass dort
so zuverlässig und wirklich mit mit sehr
viel engagement und mit sehr viel
akkuratesse gearbeitet wird so früh
mitgeteilt wird die daten es gibt nun
auf der anderen seite in bestimmten
provinzen von südafrika eben sehr stark
steigende fallzahlen uns in deutschland
glaube ich und 80 von diesen virus
sequenzen bekannt aber es muss noch
untersucht werden ob die steigenden
fallzahlen wirklich mit diesem virus typ
zusammenhängt das kann man einfach
natürlich so schnell noch nicht
beantworten und sie müssen auch
verstehen dass die bioinformatischen
analysen und die wirkliche biologische
auswirkungen natürlich auch erst noch
erforscht werden muss dass muss ja im
labor denn überprüft werden da muss die
elfjährige überprüft werden aber um es
auf den punkt zu bringen wir sind sehr
besorgt und ich hoffe sehr dass
stringent dahingehend gearbeitet wird
dass zumindest die ausbreitung dieser
variante so gut wie möglich durch
reisebeschränkungen eingeschränkt wird
zum schluss noch bislang gibt es aus
also zumindest bis vor einer stunde oder
sagen wir bis halb zehn ist mir nicht
bekannt das ist in europa oder in
deutschland diese variante bislang
gefunden wurde dafür zieht sich ihre
frage auch auf den sieg der zusatz frage
von nur eine ganz kurze kernsatz frage
weil waren erwähnt hatte dass die eu
auch maßnahmen erwägt können sie den
unterschied bitte mal erklären zwischen
stopp des flugverkehrs und
virusvarianten gebiet denn scheint ja
auf dem weg zu sein einen noch
radikaleren schritt zu gehen oder sind
die identisch die beiden schritte naja
in einer völligen stopp des flugverkehrs
heißt er tatsächlich das kein
flugverkehr nach in die eu mehr
stattfinden kann das ist eine
entscheidung die auch so jedenfalls bei
bestehender rechtslage nur die eu
treffen kann wir haben ja eine ansatz
der ihnen sagt dass zumindest die
deutschen auch nach deutschland
zurückkehren können sollen aber eben
auch nur deutsche oder mit dauerhaften
aufenthaltsstatus natürlich auch und das
kleine vier zehntägige quarantäne gilt
und ich denke das ist jetzt für den
moment auch der richtige ansatz
frage auch zu der variante ich würde mal
sagen wenn statt zu fragen gibt es hier
die man vor bitte ein geister von bild
eine frage herr sparen sie haben
angekündigt dass diese einschränkungen
auch die garantien gelten soll ab heute
nacht es sind heute früh zwei flüge
gelandet ein lufthansa flug aus kapstadt
war dabei gelandet 532 in frankfurt
welche maßnahmen wurden für die
eingereisten dieses fluges ergriffen
sind diese menschen in quarantäne
gleiche frage kommt auch von außen ich
kann diese personen die eingereist sind
noch bevor die maßnahmen in kraft treten
nur darum bitten dazu auffordern zu
hause zu bleiben eine test vorzunehmen
sich selbst zu beobachten aber natürlich
können neue ergriffene maßnahmen nur
immer ab dem zeitpunkt gelten hat dem
sie ergriffen werden das gilt ja für
andere quarantänemaßnahmen regelung auch
aber es ist eben ein aktives darum
werben bitten auffordern dass alle nicht
nur die heute morgen gelandet sind auch
die die vor drei tagen fünf tagen oder
zehn tagen oder meidling auch 20 tagen
aus südafrika und der region in
deutschland angekommen sind im zweifel
einen test und zwar einen pcr-test
idealerweise
in dem zusammenhang fragt von außen theo
geers von deutschland vom ob es mögliche
erkenntnisse darüber gibt ob noch
weitere flüge heute ankommen und ob es
möglichkeiten gibt passagiere die da
jetzt aus südafrika auf dem flughafen
sich bewegen zu erreichen
also das sind natürlich jetzt
erkenntnisse die wir jetzt auch im laufe
des morgens im ressort kreis miteinander
zusammen tragen das sind ja offenkundig
auch weitere ressorts mit betroffenen
verkehr das auswärtige amt
wir haben gestern abend schon die ersten
gespräche geführt heute früh früh das
fortgesetzt das war die erste wichtige
einigung und alle anderen fragen klären
wir jetzt natürlich auch sind ja
insbesondere die flughäfen in frankfurt
und münchen
die direkt flugverkehr mit südafrika in
deutschland haben und das was ich gerade
gesagt habe das ist eine ist eine
rechtliche wirkung eine bindende wirkung
und das andere ist aus unserer sicht
eben eine aufforderung die auch dringend
notwendig ist wir haben es auch schon
gesehen dass die luftfahrtgesellschaften
ihrerseits die kennen ja ihre passagiere
soweit sie kontaktdaten haben nochmal
darüber informieren wenn sie heute
angekommen sind besonders vorsichtig zu
sein und darum werden wir natürlich die
luftfahrtgesellschaften auch beten aber
die rechtlich bindende wirkung geht
natürlich nur auf geltendem recht dann
ab dem zeitpunkt des inkrafttretens
echt n tv ersparen her wieder sie hatten
beide eindringlich zu kontaktieren
aufgerufen aber beide von ihnen haben
den begriff lockdown nicht in den mund
genommen ist es nicht aber eigentlich
dass andere länder machen uns vor was
ist jetzt gerade bräuchte bundesbank
die frage ist sehr viel wichtiger was
ist damit gemeint weil ich mittlerweile
den eindruck haben wir reden immer viel
über ein zwei begriffe aber es muss ja
dann am ende konkret werden das ist doch
der eigentliche punkt und ich sehe das
ja hier allein zwischen zwei
bundesländern sozusagen die hier gerade
nahe beieinander sind
berlin und das nachbarland die einen
haben weihnachtsmärkte abgesagt die
anderen nicht ich meine das ist doch wir
haben hier die charité 400 meter weiter
die nicht die die voll ist und nichts
mehr geht und gleichzeitig haben wir
weihnachtsmärkte und ich weiß auch dass
draußen wenig ja passiert aber
weihnachtsmarkt so wirklich ihn kenne
bedeutet in aller regel dass da auch
getränke zu sich genommen werden und man
irgendwann gesellig wird also das ist
meistens so auf weihnachtsmärkten und
das passt einfach gerade nicht in die
zeit also es ist jetzt doch auch lieber
anders
wir hatten alle
alle uns anderen winter erhofft und
erwartet wir hatten im übrigen auch
viele voraussetzungen dafür
dass es ein anderer winter hätte werden
können aber dafür hätte man eben
deutlich früher auch gegensteuern müssen
so und jetzt sind tatsächlich das fängt
bei veranstaltungen an feiern
feierlichkeiten
zweig plus locker und für ungeimpfte und
mindestens mal regional ja auch ein ein
weitergehendes zurückfahren des
öffentlichen lebens
das hatte die beiden kollegen hier in
der mitte bitte was den handel starten
watson am ersparen das war es ja wir
jetzt mal sehr eindrücklich geschildert
und gefordert hat eine massive kontakt
produktion das bedeutet ja vermutlich
für sehr viele menschen dass sie zum
zweiten mal in folge des jahresende
weihnachten sehr einsam verbringen
werden
und unter anderem junge menschen haben
ja gesehen wie sie das psychisch
belastet hat in den vergangenen zwei
jahren diese einsamkeit dieses
verzichten auch auf dating auf
persönliche kontakte auf kontakt in der
familie haben sie mitleid mit den
menschen die jetzt zum zweiten mal in
folge erleben und die zweite seite was
raten sie den damit umzugehen das ist
ein massives soziales problem wieder
gesehen haben
also zuerst einmal belastet das ja uns
alle ich glaube das ist altersunabhängig
diese belastung die entsteht erst mal
durch die situation an sich in der
pandemie aber natürlich auch dadurch
dass kontakte eingeschränkt werden das
ist belastend und dass das tut mir auch
leid
wir würden das geld vermeiden aber es
ist nun mal notwendig habe immer mit mir
mit das ist das was das
robert-koch-institut mal sind die daten
glaube ich aus dem ständer oder man es
war das hier ist die impfquote die wir
jetzt haben mit dieser impfquote
war eine geringere belastung der
intensivstation vorhergesagt als wir sie
jetzt haben aber einen teil habe viele
nicht mitgelesen dann steht da oben
immerhin klein unter der annahme einer
verhaltensänderung bei steigender ets
auslastung es ist also sozusagen in
allen modellen mit hinein berechnet
worden es ist ja immer eine frage von
annahmen dass wir alle anfangen wenn die
zahlen steigen wenn die
intensivstationen voller werden wenn die
berichte kommen über das was los ist im
land das viele bürgerinnen und bürger
von sich aus verhalten verändern im
alltag das haben wir jetzt drei mal
gesehen und das hat auch dreimal mit den
entscheidenden unterschied gemacht neben
den staatlichen maßnahmen und das ist
das was wir diesmal so nicht sehen
bisher also dass wenn sie auf die
mobilitäts daten schauen auf das kontakt
verhalten ist das bis hierhin
jedenfalls nicht ansatzweise so
eingeschränkt wie wir das in den letzten
drei wellen hatten
und das ist für uns alle und die
herausfordernde situation das hat
natürlich das ist ja mal ein
zusammenspiel auf von kommunikation ich
bin öfter gefragt worden warum ist die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz so wichtig
das eine sind die entscheidungen die
getroffen werden das andere ist einfach
das eindeutig klare signal aller
verantwortlichen alle regierenden in
bund und ländern es ist ernst leute
es ist ernst und deswegen beraten wir
was zu tun ist und alleine diese dieses
gemeinsame agieren und handeln und es
öffentlich zu machen sozusagen hat bei
vielen dazu geführt dass sie von sich
aus im alltag verhandelten verändert
haben und das haben wir dieses mal bis
hierhin jedenfalls deutlich weniger und
werden gleichzeitig eben bis hierhin
nicht die staatlichen maßnahmen der
einheitlichkeit dies gebraucht hätte wir
haben über 2g im august diskutiert es
war im august nicht möglich als option
mit ins papier zu nehmen wir haben über
2g plus vor drei vier wochen schon
diskutiert also ich haben alle unseren
teil dabei aber ich will nur sagen es
hat einfach ein grund warum trotz der
impfquote
die dinge dann sich doch etwas anders
entwickelt haben als man hat vorher
gesehen was vor allem auch mit kontakt
verhalten zu tun hat und deswegen ist
das was den unterschied macht jetzt
kurzfristig und akut so schmerzhaft das
ist und so leid ist ein match
das was den unterschied macht
kurzfristig ist eben das deutlich
reduzieren von kontakten und ob die
frage die frage wieder an weihnachten
wird oder nicht
ich möchte jetzt erstmal dass wir heute
was tun und nicht zuerst
überlegen was in vier wochen ist ein
bisschen mit freund was tun dafür haben
sie das dieses mal oft besser auf dem
schirm als andere male diese
begleiterscheinungen die psychische
belastung für für menschen gibt es
sozusagen sich selbst die einsamkeit
zwingen weil sie die massen befolgen was
das da getan das hat ja offensichtlich
nicht so gut funktioniert ist erstens
dass das sehen wir und das begleiten wir
ja auch auch der frage was das an folgen
hat die belastungssituation und
tatsächlich bei
einigen und natürlich in zunehmender
zahl wird aus belastung gegebenenfalls
auch erkrankungen psychische erkrankung
behandlungsbedarf also das ist belastend
ist ist erstmal
eine situation die viele betrifft und
eine belastung ist noch nicht per se
behandlungsbedürftig aber natürlich bei
denjenigen die sozusagen auch das sehen
wir auch bei kindern wenn sie mit den
kinder- und jugendpsychologen sprechen
wo sozusagen eine disposition gibt wird
das dadurch dann noch mal verstärkt
getriggert sehen wir dass sich
krankheiten entwickeln und all das haben
wir nicht nur wie sie sagen auf dem
schirm sondern also passieren wir
natürlich auch im gespräch mit den
behandelnden mit den verantwortlichen
gesundheitssystemen wo wir auch wir
haben haben budgets weggenommen
behandlung leichter möglich gemacht
digitale angebote gefördert wo wir eben
können um das auch entsprechend zu
unterstützen
dass stephan mayer bayerische rundfunk
herr spahn sie haben gesagt die
verantwortlichen müssten noch wesentlich
mehr tun und es geht darum dass die
kontakte eben beschränkt werden wie
sehen sie vor diesem hintergrund die
maßnahmen in bayern und wo andere
hersteller glauben sie müsste auch dort
vielleicht noch nachjustiert werden und
der professor wiler noch eine frage die
leute die booster cent mittlerweile also
zweimal geimpft und geputzt hat so wenn
man sich umhört machen den eindruck sie
sind jetzt eigentlich aus dem schneider
was raten sie den dänen wass können dies
sollen die genauso viel beitragen zu
einer kontakt reduzierung als die hand
an dankeschön
also zuerst einmal ich äußere mich jetzt
nicht so der sektor zu sein zu den
massnahmen einzelnen bundesländern und
werden dann besprechen zuerst mit den
verantwortlichen vor ort ich habe da
eine etwas andere herangehensweise
ich finde in stresszeiten besprechen wir
konkrete fragen miteinander und nicht
übereinander
also zunächst mal alle die sich boostern
lassen den die beglückwünsche ich
erstmal denn nach allem was wir wissen
sind die noch einmal deutlich besser
geschützt vor krankheit und vor tod und
auch vor infektion aber
natürlich erwarte ich von uns allen dass
wir uns an die maßnahmen halten wir
wissen noch nicht genau ob
auch diese personen angesteckt werden
können wir gehen davon aus dass das
momentan so gut wie nicht der fall ist
aber wir möchten einfach dass alle
menschen dazu beitragen dass sie sich
weiter vorsichtig verhalten und
diejenigen die gepustet sind die haben
auf jeden fall einen wirklich
ausgezeichneten schutz gegen schwere
krankheit und gegen tot aber das
entbindet sie nicht davon auch die
verantwortung mit zu übernehmen für das
von kontakt verhalten ja das ist finde
ich jetzt eine solidarische maßnahme ich
kann nur sagen soll jeder froh sein
wenn er die chance gehabt sich zu fuß
dann ich kann nur wieder sagen wir
müssen drei dinge parallel zu erstens
kontakte einschränken damit das virus
sich nicht ausbeutet zweitens alle die
noch nicht geimpft sind sollen sich
gefälligst impfen lassen je früher die
impflücken geschlossen werden desto
besser ist sehen wir im nächsten
frühjahr aus das muss man einfach sagen
weil dieses virus h unterwegs ist und
das dritte alle können die gerudert
werden können sollen das bitte machen
wir müssen alle diese drei dinge
parallel machen und das gelingt eben
auch nur wenn jeder seiner verantwortung
da trägt egal ob er nun bewusster dass
oder zweimal geimpft oder 1 x games
kontakte einschränken bitte trotz allem
denn wir wissen ja nicht mit wem wir uns
umgeben wie die situation ist der
jeweiligen person also da bitte ich
wirklich die solidarität zu wahren und
ich kann nur noch einmal dringend dazu
aufrufen jetzt auch erstimpfungen machen
damit wir in der zukunft auch alle
besser vor diesen neuen wellen geschützt
sind denn es kommt ja sonst
wiederzuwählen und egal was sie jetzt
modulieren je höher die impfraten sind
desto geringer wird eine welle wie
gering oder wie hoch das vermögen wir
nicht zu sagen aber wir brauchen einfach
die immunität und dafür müssen wir so
viel wie möglich impfungen durchführen
und alle menschen mögen sich bitte
impfen lassen die das kann
in dem zusammenhang nämlich von außen
die frage von farbe rein in israel
kündigt sich die fünfte welle trotz
puste rung an wir kommen zu kommentieren
sie das war in israel als gelungenes
beispiel für die besteuerung
herangezogen wird
gut am ende des tages werden wir uns
natürlich auch weiterhin die entwicklung
in anderen teilen der welt anschauen ich
hoffe dass wir auch miteinander sage ich
selbstkritisch das sage ich habe auch
für alle anderen die es betrifft
vielleicht dann früher auch vom beispiel
aus anderen ländern lernen ich habe seit
juli wie andere auch über das thema
auffrischimpfungen gesprochen wir haben
im august beschlüsse gefasst alle
pflegebedürftigen und vor erkranken und
höchst betagten auf frisch zu impfen wir
haben anfang september vereinbart alle
über 60 jährigen aufrecht zu impfen und
das jetzt aktuell dieser druck da es in
den praxen in den impfzentren hat auch
was damit zu tun dass eben damals
sozusagen vor zwei monaten mit den
beschlüssen die über 60-jährigen
auf frisch zu impfen nicht begonnen
worden ist dann gab es die debatte stiko
empfehlungen ja nein ich will das alles
gar nicht wiederholen und mir geht es
jetzt eine beschreibung als sozusagen um
irgendeine zuweisung aber vielleicht
sollten wir uns diese prozesse in
zukunft einfach sparen sondern wenn wir
vorsorglich miteinander vereinbaren
frühzeitig aus den erkenntnissen aus
anderen ländern es sollte eine weitere
impfung geben dann sollten wir es
einfach machen und nicht noch zwei
monate hin und her diskutieren ob das
sein sollte
jordaans dann hatte ich die kollegin
formen notierten
sie hatten zu anfang gesagt dass sie
jede woche hier sitzen und warnungen
aussprechen und zu wenig was hier können
sie erklären was jetzt die letzten zwei
monate konkret davon abgehalten hat
schärfere maßnahmen durchzusetzen
beziehungsweise was jetzt im moment
davon abhält
nun es ist seit beginn der pandemie so
bis auf die bundes die zeit der bundes
notbremse dass die konkreten maßnahmen
auf
basis des bundes
infektionsschutzgesetzes von den
behörden in den ländern und kommunen zu
treffen sind ich kann keine kontakt
beschränkende maßnahmen anordnen wenn
das ihre frage war aber
sie könnten sie zb verlangen wie ein
walk down ich finde ich habe gerade
schon ziemlich deutlich gesagt was ich
erwarten war
dann gehen wir zu irgendwann heraus
angelika slavik von der sz ich wüsste
gerne herr minister wie würden sie denn
die zusammenarbeit zwischen der alten
und der neuen bundesregierung in bezug
auf die em krone politik beurteilen
es alles in allem
bemühen wir uns um eine bestmögliche
zusammenarbeit aber es gibt halt an
bestimmten stellen unterschiedliche
einschätzungen das ist glaube ich der
punkt da wo es sozusagen um konkrete
zusammenarbeit geht um
gesetzgebungsarbeit ich glaube zur
minute gibt es auch eine weitere
gesprächsrunde zwischen abgeordneten und
meinem ministerium in den fachlich
verantwortlichen etwa zu der frage
verpflichtende impfung für bestimmte
einrichtung das muss ja miteinander
besprochen werden innen und
justizministerium also wir arbeiten ja
so verstehe ich das auch als
geschäftsführer regierung natürlich um
auch die werden der mehrheit die in mehr
bildung befindliche mehrheit zu
unterstützen und das klappt gut
aber am ende des tages
sozusagen erarbeiten wir das natürlich
was was gewünscht ist
so und dann ich kann nur vorschläge
unterbreiten ob sie genommen werden oder
nicht entscheiden natürlich diejenigen
die die parlamentarische verantwortung
und mehrheit haben aber da wo es eben
konkrete zusammenarbeit und erarbeitung
gibt da läuft das dann auch dann auch
gut
wie gesagt was es gibt ist jedenfalls
mein eindruck bis hierhin vielleicht
ändert er sich jetzt auch zeitnah
hoffentlich ist eine unterschiedliche
einschätzung der lage und das was
kurzfristig notwendig ist er war ich
sage noch einmal ich meine dass das sag
ich jetzt mal an alle verantwortlichen
in bund und ländern wir haben jetzt eine
woche lang jeden tag hoch und runter
eine impfpflicht diskutiert kann man
alles machen aber das ist nicht das
thema dieser tage das thema dieser tage
ist wie wir diese welle brechen und
vielleicht nutzen wir die politische
kraft und aufmerksamkeit mal für das was
auf den intensivstationen los ist und
was getan werden muss und meinetwegen
können wir direkt anschließend dann auch
alle anderen themen besprechen ich finde
die reihenfolge falsch und das sind halt
unterschiedliche einschätzung die
natürlich dann auch bleiben
nachfrage fühlen sich machtlos im
augenblick
naja wir entscheiden ja also die
entscheidung heute morgen in südafrika
zum virusvarianten gebiet zu erklären
ist eine regierungsentscheidung und das
was die verantwortung ist und auch die
entscheidungsbefugnis eines ministers
und einer regierung in dieser situation
die nutzen wir auch das was ich als
minister entscheiden kann entscheide ich
auch in meiner verantwortung muss ich am
ende auch verantworten vor innen vor den
bürgerinnen und bürgern vor mir selbst
und die dort notwendigen entscheidungen
kann ich auch treffen die treffe ich
auch wenn es um gesetzgebung geht
sozusagen die grundlage für das handeln
dann ist das eben tatsächlich natürlich
eine besondere situation grad also eine
vergangenheit wusste ich eben im
zusammenspiel mit meiner fraktion mit
der mehrheit im deutschen bundestag wenn
wir einen weg gehen wenn ich bestimmte
dinge tue und rückkopplung dann kann ich
sie auch durchsetzen das ist im moment
anders aber das ist eben die
besonderheit main das ist nun mal so
nach einer wahl mit einem ergebnis wie
es war wo eben einen teil der regierung
ausscheidet
gesetzgeberisch habe ich im moment
natürlich
logischerweise er eine beratende
funktion
ersparen die schärfsten kontakt
beschränkungen in der eu gelten seit
gestern in der slowakei ein zweiwöchiger
lockdown mit ausnahme von schulen wegen
zur arbeit und in versorgung wie weit
sind wir entfernt in deutschland und an
solchen von einer solchen vollbremsung
der kontakte und wüssten sie nicht sagen
es ist das als paket als maßnahmenbündel
was wir in deutschland auch braucht also
modell nowacki
umso stärker will jetzt auf die bremse
treten desto besser das ist das was ich
alles was wir jetzt nicht entscheiden
alles was wir jetzt nicht reduzieren an
kontakten wird in zwei oder vier wochen
im zweifel drastischer maßnahmen
notwendig machen und das glaube ich muss
man im moment verstehen müssen auch alle
verstehen deswegen kann man eben nicht
auf zehn tage noch warten und gucken
zumal ja eines noch passieren wir jetzt
selbst wenn es ab morgen keine infektion
mehr in deutschland geben
und das haben wir auch schon oft genug
dargestellt allein mit den 150000
infektionen der letzten zwei tage wird
es 1000 zusätzliche intensivpatienten in
den 14 tagen geben das ist schon
entschieden das heißt die belastung die
da ist übrigens mit mehr jüngeren die
auch länger auf der intensivstation
liegen die belastungen die da ist wird
sich so oder so noch weiter verstärken
die hat ihren höhepunkt leider selbst
wenn wir es jetzt zu 100 prozent stoppen
noch nicht erreicht deswegen ja das ist
ja unser appell
tatsächlich massive einschränkungen von
kontakten und
regional erforderlich daneben auch eine
vollständige gehe davon aus dass sie
informiert sind über die gespräche des
kanzleramtsministers helge braun mit den
chefs der staatskanzleien der länder
dort haben offenbar länder erklärt und
käme an einem flächendeckenden lockt
dauernd wohl nicht vorbei ist dass der
ansatzpunkt dafür dass die länder und
der bund sich über eine gemeinsame
definition von lok da und der dann
föderal gemeinsam beschlossen wird
verständigen haben oder verständigen
können also entscheiden er wurde dass
ich jetzt interne gespräche kommentiert
werde ich auch nicht tun das
entscheidende ist dass wir dieses
gemeinsame verständnis endlich
entwickeln ich sage noch einmal hat das
letzte mal drei wochen gedauert bis
miteinander gesprochen wurde es sollte
nicht noch mal länger dauern sollte
einfach gesprochen und entschieden
werden
doch dann habe ich einige fragen von
außen eine frage geht auch in die
richtung also sie sagen nicht ersparen
dass die maßnahmen
gegen
infektionsschutzgesetz vorgesehen sind
bleiben
werden die nächste frage wäre jetzt
also zuerst einmal sind ja die
rechtlichen grundlagen gestern ist ja
sozusagen der wechsel gewesen in der in
der rechtlichen grundlage die da sind
noch nicht vollständig ausgeschöpft
und ich habe tatsächlich und da sind wir
wieder bei der frage die gerade da war
ich habe nicht dazu geraten im gegenteil
ich habe nicht ausdrücklich davon
abgeraten
den bestehenden maßnahmenkatalog
einzuschränken und es ist anders
entschieden worden ist auch nicht so
dass ist aber dann auch eine
verantwortung derjenigen dies
entschieden haben und dass das hätte
nicht sein müssen aus meiner sicht was
die frage angeht eines gremiums pandemie
rat wie immer sie es nennen wollen
was dabei für den eindruck erweckt wird
als hätten wir bisher keine krisen
stelle also der krisenstab in es gibt
der takt glaube ich nächste woche zum 99
mal
wir haben ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
und gesundheitsminister konferenzen
mindestens einmal die woche manchmal
fünf mal die woche nach jeweiliger lage
wir haben auf arbeitsebene zwischen den
gesundheitsministerien und den
zuständigen behörden in bund und land
mehrfach wöchentlich austausch
krisenstäbe also es gibt ziemlich viele
gremien die braucht es im föderalen
staat auch um jeden tag miteinander die
dinge abzustimmen wenn es jetzt einen
weiteren gibt
kann man das hier machen aber ich finde
man muss auch dabei deutlich machen dass
das jetzt keine innovation ist sondern
das ist natürlich wie sich das gehört
tägliches abstimmen aller beteiligten
auch in krisen stellen gibt und was die
wissenschaftliche beratung und
begleitung angeht ich jetzt aktuell
heute morgen an diesem freitag nicht den
eindruck dass die entscheidungen zu
treffen sind mangels wissenschaftlicher
und der nahrung nicht getroffen werden
also auch ob das jetzt ein zusätzliches
gremium gibt es das begleitet oder nicht
das kann man machen
wir haben regelmäßigen austausch
zwischen experten
experten auch interdisziplinär
gehabt das war jetzt nicht formal in
einem rad sondern er auch informell aber
alles auch transparent sie können bei
uns auf der homepage alle die vielen
beratungen die wir im sommer und herbst
gemacht haben mit expertinnen und
experten nachvollziehen wir haben
natürlich zuvörderst institutionalisiert
die wissenschaftliche beratung durch das
robert-koch-institut
wenn es auch da ein neues gremium gibt
scheidet das ja nicht auch da eine
interdisziplinäre zusammenarbeit zu
haben aber weder das eine noch das
andere löst das akute thema und das
akute thema das entscheidung getroffen
werden müssen scheitert nicht daran dass
krisenstäbe fehlen oder das
wissenschaftliche beratung fehlt aber es
braucht politische
verantwortungsübernahme für entscheidung
sie haben ja gesagt
dass das ist möglich was was glaube ich
und das meine ich jetzt wirklich vor
brust frei sondern das ist ja eine
gemeinsame
erfahrung und lehrer ich glaube einfach
dass das sehr wichtige instrument der
ständigen impfkommission
keines ist für pandemie zeiten
also dass die da wird eine unheimlich
wichtige arbeit geleistet ehrenamtlich
übrigens und dafür bin ich sehr dankbar
diese wissenschaftliche expertise und
arbeit gibt es in wenigen anderen
ländern auf der welt so die frage ist
nur ob sozusagen in einer pandemie und
gesundheitskrise
das nicht doch einen anderen mechanismus
braucht für empfehlungen zum impfen als
den herkömmlichen sozusagen mit dem man
ansonsten impfempfehlungen entwickelt
und dass das ist zum beispiel punkt ja
der muss auf jeden fall aus meiner sicht
einer einer prüfung und veränderung
unterzogen werden das sage ich in
ausdrücklicher dankbarkeit für die
arbeit der ständigen impfkommission
sie kann ja nichts dafür dass sozusagen
keine andere struktur in so einer phase
dann da vielleicht wenn ich nur ganz
kurz ergänzenden leuten möchte wir haben
alle daten alle informationen die
benötigt werden um sachgerecht zu
entscheiden es gibt ein dashboard wo
täglich aktualisiert wird es gibt einen
trend bericht es gibt ein wochenbericht
es gibt zahlen über testungen über impf
effektivität alle informationen die
gebraucht werden um eine entscheidung zu
treffen sind vorhanden in realtime und
das ist so und das ist seit monaten so
und das bleibt ja auch so
ist also diese art von informationen ist
gegeben und ist vorhanden
ich hatte sie übersehen so
dass man sich ja mehr grad auf die stiko
schon zu sprechen kommen die wird ja
auch dafür kritisiert so die langsamkeit
in der pandemie in einem interview hat
thomas mertens jetzt kritisiert die
stiko sei auch deshalb so langsam
gewesen weil es an personal gefehlt habe
warum haben sie in so einem
entscheidenden punkt der stiko nicht
ausreichend mittel zur verfügung
gestellt
also mir gegenüber hat der professor
mehrins ein personalbedarf bisher nicht
geäußert
wenn das so ist profitieren gleich
nachher an und sprechen mit ihm darüber
eine nachfrage
in israel wurde neben verfehlungen ja
immer früher gegeben und der ehemalige
corona berater der israelischen
regierung und die ganz so hat auch
kritisiert dass die deutsche politik
sich eben zu stark auf die stiko
verlassen hat nicht eben so was wie
einen im krisenstab eingerichtet hat der
eben schnelle entscheidungen treffen
könnte war es im nachhinein ein fehler
und sind sie weil sie das nicht angeregt
haben dann auch zuständig oder
mitverantwortlich für die situation
jetzt wissen sie wir haben wir nicht mal
ein paar am konkreten beispiel die
auffrischimpfungen übrigens kann ich das
bei den kinder empfunden 12 bis 17
jährigen genauso nachzeichnet die 17
verantwortlichen gesundheitsministerin
und gesundheitsminister von bund und
ländern haben jeweils sowohl bei den
impfungen der 12 bis 17 jährigen wie bei
der auffrischimpfung
als zuständige minister für die
öffentliche gesundheit das vorsorgliche
impfung empfohlen bzw im kinder
jugendlichen fall angeboten und möglich
gemacht und es war übrigens auch in
absprache weil herr professor mehrins
und ich das gemeinsame verständnis haben
dass eine stiko empfehlung was anderes
ist als eine public health empfehlung
also eine frage der öffentlichen
gesundheitsvorsorge in einer an dem die
situation das heißt wir haben da gar
kein dissens gehabt der dann
gelegentlich
beschrieben wurde haben wir bis heute
nicht gar kein dissens in der frage dass
das unterschiedliche dinge sind aber
wenn die 17 verantwortlichen
gesundheitsminister als leiter ihrer
gesundheitsbehörden diese entscheidung
treffen dann ist die aus meiner sicht
auch die die gelten muss aber dann
hatten wir anschließend diskussionen
dafür ist das jetzt das was in den
arztpraxen umgesetzt wird oder all das
kennen sie ja ich muss das nicht
nachzeichnen und das ist offensichtlich
in diesem fall also die entscheidung
sind ja getroffen worden auch von
denjenigen die für öffentliche
gesundheit zuständig sind aber sie sind
offenkundig oder brauchen vielleicht
eine andere untermauerung in einem
regelwerk damit sie das wir haben auch
die haftungsfragen also weiter heißt hat
wir haben per gesetz die haftungsfragen
geklärt
das war auch alles klar die
impfverordnung formuliert den anspruch
also der anspruch des jähnigen auf die
impfung wie auch auf die vergütung auch
das ist klar geregelt und trotzdem ist
da dieser punkt immer wieder entstanden
wo es dann hieß aber nur wenn die stiko
empfiehlt und das ist aus meiner sicht
und das sag ich noch einmal das
eigentlich vorwurf frei sondern
beschreibend keine gute situation und
das ist einer der punkte die mit dazu
geführt haben dass wir beim
auffrischimpfung einfach
nicht schnell genug waren in einer zeit
im september wo was hätten noch sein
können
die der hinweise auf personalausstattung
stiko darauf weist christian geinitz von
der faz in kam auch von dem stiko
mitglied martin terhardt im
deutschlandfunk heute morgen
fragen von außen noch mal es gibt
verschiedene fragen von thorsten maibaum
vom deutschen ärzteblatt von klaus remme
von deutschlandfunk nach der
verfügbarkeit von moderner
zusammengefasst stimmt ist wie von der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung in
den raum gestellt und im deutschlandfunk
heute morgen auch von ministerpräsident
wort gesagt es gebe lieferengpässe bei
bayern keck und moderner
also ich sag ich sage noch einmal wir
liefern anfang dieser woche nächste
woche montag dienstag
sechseinhalb millionen dosen booster
dosen von moderner aus das ist auch die
bestellte größenordnung
es ist aber natürlich ein logistisches
also es wird ja jetzt über die logistik
des großhandels der apotheken er
abgewickelt in der ganzen republik dass
das jetzt sozusagen nicht lokal in der
logistik gleich verfügbar ist
die garantie kann ich halt nicht geben
ich kann nur sagen der bund wird
innerhalb von zehn tagen
18 millionen booster dosen ausgeliefert
haben 18 millionen booster dosen
sind geimpft worden in den letzten
sieben tagen dreieinhalb millionen
das heißt da ist jedenfalls in dem
gesamtsystem
nicht also ist genug impfstoff da heißt
das dass jetzt durch die logistik
großhandel apotheke arztpraxis sozusagen
in diesem auch um stellen wir stellen
gerade innerhalb von zehn zwölf tagen
das ein system das
in einem anderen rhythmus war über den
sommer weil die bestellung ich meine wir
hatten wochen da hatten wir noch
hunderttausende bestellungen und jetzt
fahren wir auf einmal in einer woche
zehn millionen dosen wieder raus das
muss irgendwie alles auch wieder voll
sich einspielen dann in den mechanismen
in der logistik deswegen kann das sein
das ist das was ich heute morgen auch
schon vor ein zwei drei stellen
berichtet bekommen habe sozusagen in der
verteilung in der fläche das jetzt nicht
von einem tag auf den anderen gelingt
aber die dosen jedenfalls sind da in
dieser woche ausgeliefert und werden
auch am montag dienstag ausgeliefert und
zwar in der gerade genannten
größenordnung wenn wir haben uns
vorgenommen bis weihnachten je nachdem
wer sich öffentlich geäußert hat aber
zwischen 20 und 30 millionen
impfungen zu machen da sind 18 millionen
ausgelieferte dosen finde ich schon mal
ein ziemlich großer schritt dahin
dann schließlich an eine frage von
stefan lange von der augsburger
allgemeinen der mit blick auf
medikamente gegen erkrankungen fragt hat
deutschland wie beispielsweise
österreich
ausreichend medikamente gegen
erkrankungen bestellt macht eine
bevorratung sehen gibt es da womöglich
schon bestellungen also zuerst einmal
was monoklonale antikörper angeht haben
wir schon im november letzten jahres uns
bevorratet auch das hat in der bewertung
dieses kaufs in den letzten zwölf
monaten unterschiedliche einschätzungen
gehabt
aber das würde ich auch nicht alles noch
mal beschreiben im nachhinein hat es
sich jedenfalls als richtig
herausgestellt wir sehen bei diesen
monoklonalen antikörpern die hier als
infusion über drei bis fünf stunden zu
geben sind das also sehr aufwändig sehr
frühzeitig idealerweise bei
risikopatienten oder gruppen wo es
wahrscheinlichen schwereren verlauf gibt
dass die wirklichen unterschied machen
und wir sehen was mich freut
dass auch endlich der das abfordern also
die sind ja da sie müssen nur
abgefordert werden und bestellt werden
und dann in die versorgung kommen dass
das deutlich zugenommen hat den letzten
drei vier wochen das heißt also sind
auch viel viel stärker in der versorgung
als das vorher der fall ist aufgrund
auch der bedarfslage das ist das was wir
schon haben dann gibt es
sowohl neue monoklonale antikörper
intramuskulär die also nicht mit
infusionen sondern der spritze gegeben
werden können von astra zenica in der
entwicklung noch nichts davon ist
zugelassen und wir müssen natürlich auch
immer die daten bewerten das eine ist
die pressemitteilung das andere ist
schon nochmal zweimal hinzuschauen ob
die daten und das machen das bfarm und
das paul ehrlich institut jeweils dann
auch auch eine grundlage haben und ich
habe hier glaube ich schon mal gesagt
und wir sind in verhandlungen aber in
sehr konkreten sowohl mit ms.de wie mit
pfizer was die antiviralen tabletten an
geht das natürlich noch leichter in der
einnahme ist eine infusion wenn man das
über tabletten machen kann und wir
machen uns auch gedanken darüber wie wir
die so ins system bringen dass sie dann
auch sehr frühzeitig die patientinnen
und patienten dies betrifft erreichen
aber es ist übrigens so nur damit dass
auch einmal gehört ist ich habe auch
selbst ja mit mit den entsprechenden und
daneben gespräche geführt das ist
geradezu das halt 190 staaten auf der
welt im zweifel diese produkte haben
wollen
oder zumindest mal viele
und das ist das natürlich erst mal zu
beginn auch wieder knappe güter sind und
deswegen kümmere ich mich ja auch
persönlich weil solche dinge klappen
dann nur wenn dann auch auf höchster
politischer ebene die entsprechenden
gespräche mit geführt und begleitet
werden
aber es ist natürlich dann auch eine
herausforderung sozusagen im weltweiten
wettbewerb mit unternehmen die nicht per
se ihren sitz in deutschland haben
dann auch immer zu entsprechenden
abschlüssen zu kommen aber wir sind dran
frage an herrn wieder von thomas hommel
von der ärzte zeitung
der chef der vertragsärzte gassen hat
sich empört hoch empört gezeigt über
ihre kritik der ärztlichen
standesvertreter würden eigeninteressen
über das gemeinwohl stellen bleiben sie
bei ihrer aussage wird gefragt
nun wir haben in den letzten monaten ja
vieles erlebt ich erinnere nur an die em
starten etwa die erfassung der impf
daten durch die regelungen die von den
kassen jetzt im bundes vor allem durch
gesetzt wurden ist es dem robert koch
institut unter anderem gar nicht möglich
die impf daten auf individueller ebene
zu erfassen das hat sicher nicht die
pandemie bekämpfung erleichtert ich bin
der ansicht dass man in einer notlage
und ich denke das haben wir heute hier
auch noch einmal klar gemacht in einer
notlage sollte man
ergebnisorientiert handeln und
ergebnisorientiert entscheiden und wenn
wir
merken dass momentan insbesondere die
hausärzte wirklich auch überlastet sind
es gibt einige bundesländer in denen
auch ein großteil der hausärzte wir sind
daten aus rheinland pfalz zum beispiel
kann ein großteil der hausärzte sagt
'ich packe das nicht mehr ich bin
erschöpft die da gibt es patienten die
sich anpöbeln weil ich ihn nicht
innerhalb kurzer zeit einen impftermin
gebe da finden ja auch viele dinge statt
wenn also quasi diese kapazität der
hausärzte die pauschal mit 3 5 millionen
dosen einfach so pro woche behandelt
wird wenn sie gar nicht mehr da ist und
wenn wir jetzt in einer situation stehen
wo wir bis weihnachten
wie minister spanien ausgeführt etliche
millionen dosen für impfen wollen dann
müssen wir offensichtlich zusätzliche im
kapazitäten schaffen und dann sollten
wir die auch schaffen und dann sollten
wir eben auch in der lage sein
vielleicht kurzfristig bestimmte
änderungen vornehmen die einfach im sinn
dienen dass bei diesem land helfen so
vielen menschen wie möglich zu impfen
und wenn es dann standesrechtliche
beschränkungen dort gibt dann sollte man
darüber nachdenken ob wir die zumindest
temporär einfach aufhebt das ist eine
ganz nüchterne feststellung und
die empörung
die ich über viele äußerungen von herrn
gassen empfinde habe ich hier noch nie
geäußert werde auch zukünftig nicht
äußern aber mein ziel ist es und das ist
das ziel von allen die hier
verantwortung tragen dass wir in unserem
land dafür sorge tragen wollen dass so
wenig wie möglich wie menschen sterben
und so wenig menschen wie möglich
infiziert werden und schwer erkranken
und da sind impfungen der beste weg und
dann kann ich nur dafür bitten darum
dass wir alle schranken barrieren senken
die dazu führen dass weniger menschen
impfen können als es faktisch getan
werden kann und es ist so dass der
effekt tatsächlich temporär auch von
anderen kräften durchgeführt werden kann
wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin ich bin in
meinem leben oft geimpft worden in der
regel bin ich von der arzthelferin
geimpft worden und damit habe ich mich
auch mal gut gefühlt ich sehe auch kein
problem warum das nicht auch außerhalb
von arztpraxen geschehen kann
wir sind über die zeit die wir uns
vorgenommen haben um die sie mitgebracht
haben schon raus eine frage jetzt geht
würde ich gerne von außenstellen anne
days & blumberg gibt es pläne konsens zu
plänen sagen patienten aus deutschland
kliniken ins ausland zu fliegen stimmt
ist dass bereits solche flüge nach
portugal gegeben hat
also da meine erkenntnis hat es diese
flüge
nicht gegeben
das ist hat ja viele aspekte
das verlegen innerhalb deutschlands ist
jetzt glaube ich auch aus sicht der
patientinnen und patienten und der
angehörigen in vielfacher hinsicht auch
das was viele sich wünschen und erwarten
es gibt regionale zusammenarbeit sehr
eng in den grenzregionen etwa baden
württemberg frankreich saarland
frankreich zum beispiel
sowohl natürlich auch in den lagezentren
die es dort miteinander über die grenze
gibt diese frage immer wieder erörtert
wird
aber ein flug nach portugal ist jetzt
für wäre jetzt für jemanden in einer
entsprechenden behandlungssituation
schon auch eine ziemliche belastung das
findet übrigens auch sehr viele
ressourcen insofern wäre das jetzt nicht
der erste gewählte weg werden jetzt auch
in anderen ich bin übrigens sehr dankbar
ich das noch hinzufügen darf für auch
einfach die solidarität und
unterstützungsangebote die wir aus der
ganzen europäischen union erhalten sowie
andere eben auch sich auf uns verlassen
konnten als sie in schwierigen
situationen waren übrigens nordrhein
westfalen hat dieser tage auch patienten
aus den niederlanden in geringer zahl
aber auch aufgenommen also wir helfen
uns miteinander und untereinander in der
europäischen union wir helfen auch
anderen staaten mit monoklonalen
antikörpern die in einer notlage sind
auch dieser tage wieder innerhalb der eu
das ist wirklich ein sehr gutes
solidarisches zusammenarbeit in der
europäischen union wie man es sich
wünscht und wie es sein soll und muss
und gleichzeitig ist ein flug nach
portugal jetzt nicht das mittel der
ersten wahl allein aufgrund der
entfernung
der minister vielen dank dass ihr uns zu
ende hier geht es gleich mit der
regierungspressekonferenz weiter